mes chers collègues si vous voulez pour
ne pas terminer trop tard je vous
propose que nous reprenions nos nos
travaux Monsieur le Directeur Général
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
après l'audition du président de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire ASN nous
venons nous en venons à l'audition du
directeur général de l'Institut de Radi
protection et de sûreté nucléaire
Jean-Christophe Niel vous avez déjà eu
l'opportunité de vous exprimer dans le
cadre des auditions du rapporteur et du
rapporteur pour avis mais il nous a
semblé essentiel que vous puissiez
également nous présenteer votre point de
vue en plinière devant les commissaires
des deux commissions et l'ensemble des
groupes représentés comme je l'ai fait
en début de matinée avec Monsieur de
rosuk j'aimerais vous partager l'état
d'esprit qui est le mien à l'amorce de
ce chantier législatif sans entrer à ce
stade dans les considérations de fond
concernant l'opportunité de la réforme
notre priorité je le dis en tant que
président de la commission en charge des
politique de prévention des risques est
clair nous souhaitons maintenir notre
sûreté nucléaire à un niveau d'exigence
le plus élevé possible en l'adaptant aux
enjeux de notre décennie et de ces
avenir l'opportunité de la relance du
nucléaire dans notre pays qui constitue
un débat majeur pour notre nation et qui
nous mobilisera dans le cadre du projet
de loi souveraineté énergétique est une
problématique d'un autre ordre ne nous y
trompons pas le texte qui va nous
mobiliser dans les prochaines semaines
ne nous amène pas à nous positionner
pour ou contre l'énergie nucléaire il
nous est demandé de réfléchir au cadre
le plus adapté pour nos cons yen pour
assurer leur sécurité protéger la santé
la salubrité publique la protection de
la nature et de l'environnement tout en
garantissant un niveau de transparence
satisfaisant vous l'aurez compris il me
semble nécessaire de dissocier les deux
sujets même s'ils sont liés un système
de surreté irréprochable et une
transparence préservée voire accrue sont
des conditions cineéquanon de
l'acceptabilité sociale du nucléaire
sans laquelle la relance de la filière
ne pourra pas se faire je cède
maintenant la parole à ma collègue
Dominique estros Sasson président de la
commission des affaires économiques
avant de vous laisser monsieur Niel nous
partager des premiers éléments dans le
cadre d'un propos
liminire merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président en vous saluant monsieur le le
directeur général et l'ensemble des
personnes qui qui vous accompagnent pour
cette audition et en saluant de nouveau
le président de la Commission de
développement durable nos deux
rapporteurs et l'ensemble de nos
collègues comme j'ai pu l'indiquer dans
l'audition précédente du président de
l'ASN à l'heure de la relance de la
filière française du nucléaire la
réforme de la gouvernance de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la Radi prototection qui
est proposée par le gouvernement peut
constituer une opportunité pour
consolider les processus d'expertise
d'instruction d'autorisation et de
contrôle pour autant cette réforme ne
peut réussir que si elle ne déstabilise
pas les règles de sécurité et de sûreté
la disponibilité des compéten et Infiné
la confiance du public c'est pourquoi
l'examen du projet de loi soumis au
Sénat doit être approfondi et exigeant
en pesant les avantages mais aussi les
inconvénients d'une telle réforme donc
sans vous poser trop de questions parce
que je pense que à la fois les
rapporteurs et nos collègues vont le
faire de nouveau attirer votre attention
sur quatre points qui reviennent d'une
façon assez récurrente en premier lieu
au regard des exemples étrangers quels
sont pour vous les bénéfices attendus
d'un modèle de sûreté nucléaire et de
radiprotection intégré tel qu'il est
pratiqué aux États-Unis au Royaume-Uni
ou en Espagne et à contrario quels sont
pour vous les risques d'une telle fusion
que pensez-vous du calendrier tel qu'il
est proposé par le gouvernement pour
réaliser la réforme autre point puisque
nous avons été très vigilants au niveau
du Sénat dans l'examen du projet de loi
nouveau nucléaire où nous avions
souhaité que effectivement ce point-là
puisse être envoyé à l'OPEX pensez-vous
que les suites données donc au rapport
de l'OPEX ont tout été prises en
considération dans ce projet de loi et
en particulier un certain nombre de
recommandations sur la séparation entre
l'expertise et la décision ou à
contrario que des recommandations
ont-elles été omises et pour vous quell
seraient ces recommandations qui
auraient été omises et qui pourrai être
de nature à être intégré dans le projet
de loi et puis au-delà de cette réforme
quelle est votre vision de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la radioprotection de
demain car nous nous apprêtons
effectivement à légiférer pour les
prochaines décennies la mise en service
des nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires
n'étant pas attendu avant
2037 dans ce contexte ne faut-il pas
mieux intégrer les nouveaux risques tels
que la résilience des réacteurs
nucléaires au changement climatique et
leur cyber résilience ne faut-il pas
mieux tenir compte des nouveaux acteurs
du nucléaire dont les opérateurs des
petits réacteurs modula voilà en tout
cas ces premières questions que je
souhaitais vous poser en vous passant la
parole pour ce propos liminaire Monsieur
le
Directeur les rapporteurs oui on va
donner la parole on va donner la parole
au rapporteur Pascal
Martin merci Madame la présidente
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur Monsieur le Directeur
général je vous ai déjà entendu en tout
début de cycle d'audition c'était
d'ailleurs la première matinée après le
président de de l'ASN au terme de ce
cycle j'ai identifié cinq enjeux
centraux de ce projet de loi qui doivent
être à mes yeux approfondis j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'évoquer ces enjeux tout à
l'heure avec le président de la SN il me
semble important d'avoir sur ces mêmes
sujets également votre point de vue
premier enjeu l'humain la Sûreté
Nucléaire repose d'abord sur des
compétences sur des experts et des
chercheurs qui doivent être au cœur de
notre réflexion je l'avais déjà rappelé
en tant que rapporteur budgétaire sur
les crédits relatifs à la prévention des
risques la relance du nucléaire
nécessitera la création de 100000 postes
durant les 10 prochaines années dans ce
contexte fortement concurrentiel nous
devons être particulièrement attentifs à
assurer l'attractivité de la Sûreté
Nucléaire Monsieur le Directeur général
dans l'hypothèse de la création d'une
nouvelle autorité de nucléaire comment
la nouvelle autorité de sûreté nucléaire
et de radiprotection pourrait-elle être
suffisamment attractive notamment pour
les jeunes chercheurs experts
l'éventualité d'une réorganisation
prochaine de la Sûreté Nucléaire
entraîne-t-elle déjà des conséquen sur
l'attractivité de l'IRSN comment éviter
que la période de transition inhérente à
une telle réforme indispensable entre
l'ancienne et la nouvelle organisation
ne se traduisent pas par une perte per
partielle de compét deuxième enjeu non
moins important la transparence les
Français ont aujourd'hui très largement
confiance en la robustesse de notre
système de sûreté nucléaire cette
confiance elle est le fruit d'un travail
de plusieurs décennies de tous les
acteurs qui s'est notamment traduit par
un effort accru d'information du public
pour assurer l'acceptabilité de la
relance du nucléaire il est à mon sens
souhaitable de continuer à renforcer
cette transparence l'exposé du motif des
motifs pardon du projet de loi évoque je
cite une transparence renforcée
vis-à-vis du public comment
l'asnr renforcerait-elle selon vous la
transparence de la sûreté nucléaire
alors que l'ursn publie aujourd'hui
l'ensemble de ses avis d'expertise
comment la future autorité pourrait-elle
assurer un niveau au moins équivalent
d'information au public trème enjeu la
distinction enjeu qui a été évoqué tout
à l'heure avec le président de la SN qui
a été évoqué tout au long de nos
auditions entre expertise et décision
c'est un principe fondamental de notre
système de sûreté nucléaire dans
l'organisation actuelle les décisions en
matière de sûreté nucléaire sont prises
par l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
tandis que l'expertise est généralement
délégué à l'IRSN pour les décisions les
plus importantes la la réforme propose
d'intégrer expertise et décision au sein
d'une même autorité dans un souci de
simplification administrative renforçant
la lisibilité et l'opérationnalité des
services quelle forme pourrait prendre
la distinction entre expertise et
décision au sein de l'organisation
unique proposée par le
gouvernement 4è et avant dernier enjeu
la recherche l'IRSN exerce aujourd'hui
une activité de recherche en matière de
sûreté nucléaire qui nourrit son
activité d'expertise cette recherche
appliquée dont l'excellence est reconnue
internationalement serait conservé dans
le cadre de la future asnr c'est précisé
dans le projet de loi le transfert à une
autorité administrative indépendante
d'activités de recherche peut susciter
quelqu interrogation la recherche
nécessite de nombreux partenariats avec
d'autres établissements de recherche
mais aussi avec les principaux
industriel du nucléaire qui seront
également contrôlés par la future
autorité la SNR pourrait-elle poursuivre
les partenariats engagés entre l'IRSN et
les principaux industriels du nucléaire
sans risque déontologique de potentiel
conflit d'intérêt enfin le dernier enjeu
que j'identifie est plus juridique il
s'agit des conditions d'élaboration du
règlement intérieur de la future
autorité j'ai pu constater au cours de
mes auditions que la plupart des sujets
les plus sensibles relatifs notamment à
la déontologie à la publication des
travaux d'expertise et à la distinction
entre expertise et décision sont renvoyé
et on peut tout à fait le comprendre au
réglement futur règlement de la future
autorité cette option a l'avantage de la
souplesse il ne faut pas tout figer dans
la loi c'est l'esprit même d'une
autorité administrative indépendante si
le législateur fait le choix de la
fusion les grandes orientations devront
être décidées par le législateur puis la
SNR devra les appliquer dans son
règlement intérieur cette solution plus
souple peut présenter cependant un
inconvénient il n'est pas garanti il y a
pas d'accusation à priori hein que les
solutions adoptées par laasnr soi
totalement conformes à l'esprit du
législateur et donc c'est ma dernière
question Monsieur le Directeur Général
comment garantir que sur des enjeux
aussi cruciaux que la transparence la
déontologie distinction entre expertise
et décision la volonté du Parlement soit
respectée vous semble-t-il pertinent
envisageable de prévoir la saisine pour
avis non pas conforme mais un avis de
l'opexte par exemple sur le projet de
règlement intérieur de la future
autorité je vous
remercie Patrick
chez Monsieur le Directeur Général
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président chers collègues rapporteurs
mes chers collègues comme comme je
l'indiiqué je suis chargé en tant que
rapporteur pour la commission des
affaires économiques de l'examen au fond
de quatre articles du projet de loi sur
les réformes du haomissaire à l'énergie
atomique et des règles de la commande
publique applicable au projet de
réacteur nucléaire et de l'examen pour
avis des autres articles du texte ayant
trait à la réforme de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la
radioprotection à mon tour je
souhaiterais vous poser les mêmes
questions que j'ai indiqué au président
de l'ASN et je m'en excuse auprès de mes
collègues qui vont m'entendre pour la
deuxème fois sur le même point alors ma
première question concerne l'application
de cette réforme d'une part contenu de
la nécessité pour la nouvelle autorité
d'élaborer un règlement intérieur étaufé
et de négocier des conventions
collectives l'échéance du 1er janvier
2025 est-elle tenable d'autre part le
mandat du président de laasn devant
prendre fin en 2024 sans possibilité de
renouvellement ne faudrait-il pas
prévoir la désignation d'un
préfigurateur
ma deuxème question porte sur le statut
de la future autorité si le statut
d'autorité
indépendante autorité administrative
indépendante est de nature à garantir
l'indépendance de cette nouvelle
instance celui d'autorité publique
indépendante lui aurait conféré une
autonomie budgétaire et une souplesse de
gestion regrettez-vous le choix opéré
par le gouvernement ma trème question
concerne les missions de la future
autorité lors de l'audition du président
de laasn par notre commission le 8 mars
dernier sur le premier projet de réforme
proposée par le gouvernement dans le
cadre de la loi nouveau nucléaire
celui-ci avait regretté que la sécurité
des installations nucléaires civiles ne
figure pas parmi les missions de la
nouvelle autorité partagez-vous cette
position ma 4e question porte sur
l'organisation de la future autorité le
projet de texte renvoie à son règlement
intérieur la séparation entre le
processus d'expertise et et
d'instruction conduit par les services
d'une part et les processus
d'élaboration des avis et des décisions
prises par le collège d'autre part ne
faut-il pas viser d'autres
actes les cas où les décisions sont
prises par le collège sont pe nombreuses
une quarantaine ne faudrait-il pas
étendre ce champ de compétence le projet
de texte renvoie également au règlement
intérieur le soin de définir les
activités d'expertise et d'instruction
qui devront faire l'objet de publication
est-ce que cela offre des garanties
suffisantes certains rapports avis au
décision ne devrai-ils pas être d'emblé
rendu public sous réserve des secrets
protégés par la
loi ma 5è série de question porte sur le
personnel de la future autorité tout
d'abord la réforme garantirat-elle
l'accueil des salariés de l' RSN dans
les conditions équivalentes à leur
situation actuelle plus encore la
complexité des instances de
représentation des personnels et des
modalités de négociation des conventions
collectives ne fait-elle pas peser le
risque d'une autorité déséquilibré à
deux vitesses entre les agents publics
et ceux privés enfin la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle prohibbe la délégation
de fonction inséparable de la
souveraineté nationale à des agents
étrangers de même que la recherche
d'infraction pénale par des agents
privés ne faudrait-il pas inscrire ces
de fou s'agissant des personnels
habilités je vous
remercie monsieur le directeur merci
donc j'ai bien com jusqu'à 15h c'est ça
ok merci merci de de de me donner la
parole madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président messieurs les rapporteurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les les les
parlementaires c'est un honneur de
répondre à vos questions et le cas
échéant je je serai aidé par
karinevw directrice générale adjointe de
l'IRSN chargé de la Sûreté Nucléaire
donc PRL smmrcl et Patrice buo directeur
de de de la stratégie ils sont aussi
accompagnés d'Emmanuel mur qui organise
les relations avec les les les les les
les parlementaires notamment alors je
vrais commencer par un rappel l'IRSN
c'est l'expert public du risque
radiologique et nucléaire et notre
métier notre mission c'est d'évaluer les
risques liés à l'utilisation des
rayonnements yoninan ionisant et ça ça
consiste en deux métiers l'expertise
pour un large spectre d'institutions
dont l'autorité de sreté nucléaire et la
recherche expertise recherche et donc
l'IRSN est un organisme scientifique et
technique alors concrètement 25 à 30 %
de notre activité actuelle est dédiée à
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
essentiellement sous la forme de 400
livrables par an 200 avis euh euh le
reste donc euh 70 à 75 % c'est de la
recherche ou de l'expertise pour
d'autres institutions on a parlé de la
défense mais ça peut être aussi les
ministères de la Santé du travail de
l'environnement des affaires étrangères
sur zaporoya par exemple c'est
évidemment des sujets qu'il faudra
traiter dans la réforme alors mon
deuxième point c'est un petit mot sur le
projet de réorganisation du contrôle qui
fait suite donc aux deux conseils de
politique cléaire des 3 février et 19
juillet au fond de quoi
s'agit-il au fond il s'agit de prévenir
les accidents nucléaires ou
radiologiques il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'un processus de fusion administrative
et budgétaire le rapport de l'Office a
évoqué un mécano
administratif je rappelle aussi que le
système de contrôle quel que soit le
risque regardé mais en parti pour la
sûreté nucléaire mais ça peut être la
sécurité dans le domain industriel est
un élément essentiel de la maîtrise des
accidents et tchernobyl Fukushima dans
le nucléaire AZF lu brisol les accidents
du Boeing 737 MAX l'ont rappeler le
potion que je voulais mentionner c'est
que la réforme voulue par le
gouvernement n'est pas la conséquence
d'une défaillance du système actuel de
contrôle que ce soit l'IRSN ou l'ASN et
ça ça a bien été rappelé dans le rapport
de l'Office Parlementaire dans un
certain nombre de rapports
parlementaires dans le rapport d'audit
de la de de l'IRS le plus récent par la
Cour des comptes et le HCS et c'est
aussi un point qui avait été mentionné
en particulier par laasn dans les
relations à haut niveau que nous pouvons
avoir de manière périodique alors ce
projet il est porté par le gouvernement
pour fluidifier les process pour
répondre à une demande en forte
augmentation le projet présente
clairement des évolutions par rapport au
projets que vous aviez pu enfin qui
avait été discuté à l'Assemblée
nationale et pas voté par l'Assemblée
nationale qui n'avait pas été éé examiné
par le Sénat d'ailleurs alors en fait
aujourd'hui le projet de loi dont nous
discutons aujourd'hui c'est trois
réformes c'est trois chantiers à mener
le premier chantier c'est
l'asnr le deuxième chantier c'est le
transfert de la dosimétrie passive au
CEA je vous ai amené un dosimètre
j'espère que je le toujours avec moi sil
est là voilà je vous pour montrer ce que
c'est c'est ces petits objets que posent
portent les professionnels ça va du
dentiste à l'opérateur de centrale
nucléaire et RSN en fabrique 1500000 par
an c'est une peti ce sont des chaînes de
fabrication donc c'est le deuxème
chantier le 3ème chantier c'est le
transfert de l'expertise de défense au
ministère des
armées les recommandations de l'office
parlementaire de février et de
juillet on les retrouve dans le projet
de loi il y a notamment les
recommandations ét les suivantes associé
la recherche et l'expertise afficher au
plus haut niveau la séparation expertise
décision garantir la transparence de
l'expertise préserver la capacité de
réponse de l'État en cas de crise
assurer l'attractivité et la
fidélisation des
salariés fournir un appui technique aux
autres autorités c'est ce que j'ai déjà
évoqué dans le domaine de la défense et
de la sécurité ou dans le domaine de la
radioprotection he notamment la
direction générale du travail Direction
générale de la santé direction générale
de la prévention des risques quelques
éléments sur la nouvelle autorité asnr
donc les missions de la SNR seraiit donc
les missions actuelles de l'ASN et de
l'IRSN sauf la dosimétrie passive et
l'expertise de
défense cette nouvelle structure elle
serait unique à plusieurs titres ce
serait d'abord la seule autorité
administrative indépendante qui en même
temps serait un organisme de recherche
ce serait aussi d'ailleurs au niveau
international la seule autorité de
sûreté organisme de recherche un certain
nombre de d'autorités de sûreté
étrangère finance des programmes de
recherche son agence de programme mais
il n en a pas en tout cas ma
connaissance qui soit organisé de
recherche c'est qu' des laboratoires des
des des paillasses des ossioscope des
détecteurs et cetera et cetera la
deuxième originalité de cette nouvelle
organisation c'est le fait de rassembler
des agents publics à peu près 500 et des
salari TR de droit privé à peu
près
1600 le le le Conseil d'État dans son
avis et la commission nationale de le
Conseil national de la transition
énergétique indique d'ailleurs que ce
dispositif présente une complexité
certaine tout ça m'amène à CIN points de
grande vigilance de l'IRSN le premier a
trait au au aux activités de recherche
il est évidemment essentiel que ces
activités de recherche s'intègrent dans
l'écosystème de recherche avec notamment
une capacité à conduire des recherches
avec les
industriels la capacité aussi à
concevoir construire et exploiter des
installations industrielles des
installations de recherche le deuxième
point que je voulais mentionner c'est la
gestion de crise donc l'organisation
prévue par la loi apportera une
clarification une liibité accrue un
certain nombre de sujets seront
néanmoins à traiter notamment
l'interface avec les les dosimètres qui
sont destinés notamment au travailleurs
en général mais en cas de crise au
personnel intervenant donc il faudra
assurer la isation de la la la mise à
disposition de cette deux passive
aujourd'hui c'est l'IRSN qui le fait et
puis il faudra aussi
éclaircir la gestion de crise dans la
partie défense puisqueaujourd'hui
l'expertise défense ou civile en cas de
crise est faite au Centre de Crise de
l'IRSN demain ce centre de crise sera
dédié à l'Autorité de sûreté civile le
troisième point c'est la séparation
expertise décision alors c'est un
principe qui est issu des grandes
catastrophes technologiques des années
80 un bal challenger tchernoby et des
grandes crises sanitaires des années 90
hein sans contaminer vachfol
euh il nous semble il me semble que ce
qui est retenu aujourd'hui dans la loi
consistant à une distinction collège
service n'est pas suffisant pour assurer
cette séparation le 4ème point de grande
vigance c'est évidemment l'attractivité
et il y aura un enjeu à
préserver dans la durée tel que c'est
l'objectif aujourd'hui dans la durée de
manière pérenne un nombre important de
salariés de de statut privé et bien
évidemment maintenir le dialogue social
il est reconnu pour être de qualité à
l'IRSN aujourd'hui le 5è et dernier
grand point de vigilance c'est
évidemment la transparence et
l'interaction avec la société
civile comme vous l'avez mentionné c'est
une condition de la confiance dans le
système de contrôle et donc il faudra
continuer la publication des expertises
techniques des recherches des éléments
qui fond de les décisions alors au-delà
de ces cinq points de grande vigilance
il y a une nécessité essentielle c'est
assurer la continuité de service pour la
réussite du plan de relance nucléaire il
y a beaucoup de rendez-vous en
2024 2025 et 2026 ça commence dès 2024
2025 j'ai remis et je je je je je peux
faire de même aujourd'hui à vous
rapporteur un schéma qui a élaboré
l'IRSN le Lairon rouge justement c'est
les années 2024 2025 qui montre une
concentration de travail du point de vue
de l'IRSN à d'expertise les décisions
arrivant ultérieurement il y a déjà des
travaux sur le PR2 depuis quelques temps
sur la prolongation d'exploitant à 40 50
60 ans selon le type de récteur sur les
smmr sur le stockage de déchets euh CGO
le deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
attirer attention c'est évidemment les
les perturbations euh euh possibles et
les risques d'instabilité c'est
d'ailleurs le Conseil supérieur de
l'énergie qui mentionne ce terme euh qui
pourrait accompagner euh cette réforme
dont j'ai rappelé la complexité
mentionnée là encore par la Cour des
comptes le Conseil d'État lopesque et un
certain nombre de de commissions et donc
pour conclure il me semble que une des
conditions de la réussite en tout état
de cause c'est les moyens les moyens
vis-à-vis de la relance et les moyens
par rapport à la réorganisation là
encore c'est un un un constat qui est
partagé par un certain nombre de de de
de rapports notamment le rapport Rapin
il y a il y a à peu près 1 an Lopez que
mentionne la Cour des comptes conseil
supérie de l'énergie le Conseil national
de la transition
énergétique évidemment cette cette autre
condition de de réussite au-delà des moy
c'est évidemment un dialogue de social
de qualité et une conduite de du
changement adapté à l'ampleur de ce de
cette évolution voilà ce que je voulais
en l'introduction madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames etieur les
parlementaires merci monsieur le
Président je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur F je vous voulez que je réponde
aux questions des comment ça merci
monsieur le Président d'cord d'accord
d'accord d'accord
d'accord des premiers éclairages nous
ont été apportés
et les interrogations qui qui vont très
certainement être les nôtres se font
aussi à la lumière de l'intervention du
président de l'ASN
et
puisque il a dû nous quitter je me
permettrai en tout cas de m'en ouvrir
certainement par écrit envers lui au
regarde des réponses qui n'ont pas pu
nous être apportés tout à l'heure
puisque nous avons quand même eu le
sentiment à écouter le plédoyer pour la
réforme qu' s'agissait finalement d'un
réquisitoire d'un réquisitoire non pas
Surel le système de à actuel mais
réquisitoire à l'égard du projet de
fusion puisque euh il y avait
semble-t-il et de
façon très établie des contradictions
assez fortes dans l'exposé qui nous a
été fait tout à l'heure sur le
fonctionnement actuel et l'éventuel
fonctionnement futur si d'aventure euh
la fusion devait voir le jour et la ma
question va être extrêmement extrêmement
brève d'après vous est-ce que la filière
électronucléaire française peut relever
les défis auxquels elle va devoir faire
face dans les années à venir en
conservant le système actuel en le
renforçant et en lui apportant des
garanties financières et humaines
notamment pour le développement des
compétences qui aujourd'hui nous font
défaut je vous remercie Yannick Jade
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Directeur
général le président longjot avait
raison de dire en introduction que c'est
pas un débat sur le
nucléaire qu'on soit pour contre le
nucléaire qu'on soit pourou contre la
relance du nucléaire on a du nucléaire
pour des décennies à venir et que on a
un enjeu commun de sûreté et de sécurité
je ve dire y compris quand on est assez
critique vis-à-vis du nucléaire c'est
aussi sur les questions de sûreté et de
sécurité donc nous avons en tant que
qu'assemblée une responsabilité
énorme puisque un président de laasn
avait dit le risque zéro n'existe pas et
donc nous avons une responsabilité
énorme en matière de sûreté et de
sécurité la présidente Estrosi Sasson
l'a
dit il y a de plus en plus de risque y
compris maintenant le risque climatique
on est dans un monde d'instabilité
évident on a un parc qui est
vieillissant donc on a
incontestablement un accroissement du
spectre des risques et
donc de la nécessité de les expertiser
correctement et on a aussi puisqu'il y a
des projets de
relance une explosion des besoins de
décision et potentiellement
d'autorisation donc sur les deux grands
acteurs et les deux grands champs de
responsabilité
on a un accroissement des
responsabilités qui est
considérable et moi je suis
assez un peu mal à l'aise dans le débat
que nous avons et que le gouvernement a
engagé sur cette réforme c'est qu'on a
l'impression que le Président de la
République dans ses
projets veut au fond passer outre tous
les procédures tout les processus y
compris parlementaires de décision et
que
l'expertise devient une forme de
contrepouvoir qu'il faudrait réduire on
a ce sentiment que dans cette réforme
apparaît l'idée que une expertise au
fond c'est un emmerdement en matière
d'autorisation si je peux me permettre
cette grossièreté et donc pour ma part
moi effectivement ça a été rappelé
plusieurs
fois le
double
l'organisation avec deux deux
institutions nous n'est pas critiqué
elle nous a paraît efficace et elle nous
a paraît j'imagine de plus en plus
nécessaire d'une certaine façon avoir le
président de la SN disait on a des
problèmes de doublon un doublon en
matière de sécurité nucléaire je trouve
que c'est plutôt une sécurité ma
question Monsieur le Directeur général
c'est qu'on entend que effectivement la
répartition entre expertise et
autorisation se ferit dans un règlement
intérieur enfin moi tout ça m'apparaît
lunaire
ça m'a paraarît lunaire que sur des
décisions aussi importantes que la
séparation entre expertise autorisation
relève non
pas d'une
responsabilité du législateur très très
forte très encadré mais d'une sorte de
règlement intérieur qui sera au même
titre que le règlement intérieur sur la
mobilité des personnels entre expertise
autorisation est-ce que vous considérez
que ça soit rattaché simplement au
règlement intérieur nous apparaît
suffisant pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens merci je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur
Devinaz merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général de
votre
éclairage on est dans le domaine de du
nucléaire et si il y a un pépin les
conséquences sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes que quand il y a le scratch d'un
avion les conséquences sont sur le plus
long terme et donc aujourd'hui votre
organisme et la SN vous êtes
reconnu pour votre compétence sur le
plan international sur le plan de
l'expertise et de la Sûreté
Nucléaire cette for cette réforme qui
est proposée elle serait intéressante si
on avait la conviction qu'elle
renforçait renforcerait les aspects de
sûreté et de sécurité donc en de votre
point de vue en quoi cette réforme
va-t-elle aller dans le sens d'un
renforcement de la sûreté et de la S
sécurité et ce qui est un élément
important pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyenes et concitoyens il y a un
autre aspect il me semble avoir lu de la
part de
l'ex-ministre que aujourd'hui vous êtes
un épique que demain vous serez dans une
agence et que demain en étant dans une
agence vous serez plus indépendant que
dans la forme actuelle alors en quoi
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas indépendant
et en quoi demain vous serez plus
indépendant Serge merou oui madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur général le
gouvernement justifie la fusion de
l'IRSN et de l'ASN
entre autres par le besoin d'augmenter
l'efficience du travail effectué et
cette fusion permettrait notamment
d'améliorer le partage d'informations et
de données mais dans le même temps le
projet de loi prévoit une séparation
entre la sûreté des installations
civiles et celle relevant des
installations
militaires vous évoquiez la
complémentarité des deux domaines lors
de votre audition à l'Assemblée
nationale nationale en octobre dernier
alors selon vous cette mesure peut-elle
présenter un frein au partage des
données finalement n'y a-t-il pas un
risque de perdre en efficacité et ma
deuxième question concerne le travail
que vous menez en terme de recherche en
partenariat par exemple avec EDF ou le
CEA ces partenaires c'est sont justement
soumis au contrôle de
l'ASN en créant une unité qui va
rassembler
l'IRSN et l'ASN ces acteurs ne
seront-ils pas réticents à mener des
recherches en partenariat avec
l'autorité qui les contrôle et si oui
comment faire face à cette perte de
compétitivité qui dégraderit le
rayonnement de
l'IRSN merci je vais donner la parole à
R tec oui merci monsieur le Président je
serai assez court je crois qu'on a eu
une une audition du président de la SN
tout à fait édifiante il y a quelques
minutes où très clairement il nous dit
aujourd'hui l'ASN n'a pas les moyens de
remplir ses mission face à la fois au
nouveau programme nucléaire au carénage
osmr et cetera et que
donc il il il regarde du côté des moyens
de l'IRSN en se disant c'est comme ça
qu'on réussira à répondre à la charge de
travail donc moi ma question est très
simple c'est est-ce que si l'IRSN doit
répondre à plus de demandes d'expertise
sur l'ensemble des champs lié à la
relance du nucléaire est-ce que vous
avez encore les moyens de répondre à
l'ensemble des autres missions puisque
la radiprotection ne se limite pas au
nucléaire vous l'avez bien dit en
introduction où est-ce que d'autres
missions devront être réduites voire
abandonné et surtout je repose la même
question que tout à l'heure est-ce que
le rôle qui est aussi de se poser des
question que personne ne se pose et de
ne pas répondre simplement à des
commandes d'études qui viendrait de
l'autorité de seté nucléaire est-ce que
ce rôle un peu out of the box pourra
encore être
rempli c'est quand même un résumé
monsieur Dantec très raccourci et rapide
de l'audition qui a été donc j'assume
mes propres résumés Madou nous nous
assumons aussi de dire que c'est pas
tout à fait ce qu' dit le président de
l'ASN nous récons ensemble
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Directeur Général effectivement j'ai
pas entendu la même chose on était
pourtant à la même réunion et bon enfin
c'est pas c'est pas le sujet profitons
du peu de temps que nous avons
pour s'enrichir du point de vue de notre
directeur général de
l'IRSN une première question concerne
concernant le l'aspect humain et personn
tout le monde s'accorde que ce soit
vous-même
ou laasn de dire on est devant des
besoins énormes par rapport aux
nouvelles missions déjà qu'on avait
renforcé au Sénat en 2023 mais aussi de
nouvelle génération de nucléaire et et
surtout d'un contexte qui va
complètement changer hier votre
interlocuteur principal c'était EDF et
et et queedf globalement je je résume
demain vous aurez des St
on aura un monde bien bien différent
donc ma ma question est-ce que la future
structure sera un atout pour attirer
plus de femmes et d'hommes pour
renforcer parce qu'on voit bien et vous
l'avez très bien dit le moyen humain et
financiers qui vont être nécessaires
est-ce que c'est un atout pour renforcer
pour attirer les personnes sachant qu'on
était plutôt dans le déclin au niveau
national puisqueil faut dire les choses
ça fait quand même 20 ans qu'on a laissé
peu d'espoir à l'avenir du nucléaire
soudainement on sa mécanique ma première
question ma deuxième question concernant
je viens d'ter parler du nouveau
nucléaire notamment jusqu'à présent en
terme de transparence sur les
territoires qu'on des centrales on le
voit bien avec lesclis ça fonctionne il
y a il y a une confiance qui s'établie
il y a quelque chose qui est né en terme
de relation demain dans le projet on va
avoir besoin de nouveaux sites où il y a
pas cette ambance où il y a pas
forcément cette connaissance cette cette
relation donc estce qu'on a pas un peu
sous-estimé dans le texte cette partie
transparence et moyen et architecture de
moyens pour cela et ma dernière con
concerne la recherche ma dernière
question euh je pense qu'on vous avez
été on a été en France dans les
pionniers sur nucléaire embrassant à la
fois l'énergie la
santé l'aspect
défense mon inquiétude donc je je pose
la question en donnant déjà un peu un
avis mon inquiétude est-ce qu'on va pas
assister quandme un affaiblissement de
l'aspect recherche dans la nouvelle
structure contenu qu'il a des points qui
vont un peu quitter or lorsqu'on parle
du neutron de
l'atome il est unique cas départ
merci jean-fançois tu as plus de
question de ton côté question alors pour
ma part il reste Bernard pasadame mais
pas vu qu'elle avait levé la main
excuse-moi
monsieur le Président pour justifier
cette fusion la ministre a mis en avant
le manque de réactivité lors des
situations de crise évoquant notamment
la centrale de civau dont la reconnexion
au réseau après la résolution des
problèmes de corrosion aurait pris
beaucoup de temps trop de temps
considérez-vous que la fusion des deux
entités permettrait véritablement une
amélioration des délais alors que la
convention qui les lit fixe des délais
qui semblent avoir été toujours
respectés en ce qui concerne
l'IRSS par ailleurs je pense qu'il
serait intéressant d'évaluer réellement
le gain de temps que cette nouvelle
organisation administrative indépendante
permettrait d'obtenir et qu'elle ne se
fora pas surtout au détriment de la
transparence et de la sécurité à
laquelle bien sûr nous sommes tous très
attachés alors Bernard bu et on
terminera avec Daniel salmon merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président comp tenu du niveau
relativement faible des rémunérations
existante sur certains métiers en
tension dans la filière nucléaire entre
l'IRSN et le reste de la filière
l'article 11 prévoit que l'IRSN et l'ASN
consacre respectivement 15 millions
d'euros et 700000 € à l'augmentation des
salariés et des contractuels de droits
public en 2024 afin d'engager un
rééquilibrage dès 2024 en parallèle de
ces dispositions le gouvernement porte
une réflexion visant à accroître les
enjeux d'attractivité pour les
fonctionnaires de la future autorité en
veillant à maintenir un équilibre
nécessaire pour chacun des corps de
rattachement entre les différentes
affectations selon vous y aurait-il
d'autres pistes à envisager pour
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers
dans la filière du
nucléaire Daniel
salmon merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Général euh
votre la personne que nous venons
d'auditionner euh le président de l'ASN
a parlé de contexte hors norme est-ce
que le contexte hors norme hors norme
est compatible avec le domaine du
nucléaire déjà c'est la première
question puisque il nous a bien parlé de
défis extrêmes qui sont devant nous avec
la sécurité du parc vieillissant avec
les nouveaux pr et les SMR qui amènent
des nouvelles technologies peu maîtrisés
et qui vont être diffusés dans euh dans
les des espaces qui ne sont pas
nucléarisés à l'heure actuelle
euh on recherche également des des
alternatives quelles évolutions pourrait
être apporté au modèle actuel pour
répondre aux enjeux ou est-ce que on est
absolument obligé d'aller vers cette
cette fusion donc voilà c'est la
question est-ce que vous avez des
propositions pour et bien aller dans
dans le sens d'une amélioration du
système dual qui de toute évidence donne
de nombreuses satisfactions aujourd'hui
merci alors il y a encore une dernière
intervention de Catherine Loisier merci
madame la Présidente monieur le
Président c'est juste pour mon
intervention enfin mon mon information
euh on nous dit que dans la plupart des
des des des pays euh ces autorités sont
d'ors et déjà regroupés euh donc je
voudrais savoir quels sont en fait les
pays qui agissent comme la France
c'est-à-dire avec des autorités
distinctes et est-ce que à votre
connaissance elles sont sur la même
réflexion de de de regroupement merci
voilà Monsieur le Directeur général on
vous laisse le soin de répondre à ces
questions je vous remercie pour la
richesse des des des questions alors je
vais peut-être commencer par la première
et finalement la dernière question
puisque les deux concernent les les
modèles intégrés alors dans tous les
pays qui ont un parc nucléaire il y a
besoin d'une expertise technique en
sreté nucléaire ça c'est partagé par
tout le monde dans tous les pays une
autorité de sûreté nucléaire c'est la
convention de sûreté internationale de
sûreté qui le demande et tous les pays
tous les pays ont une autorité par
contre il y a différents
modèles sur l'interaction entre
l'Autorité de sûreté qui a besoin de
s'appuyer sur expertise expertise
technique l'expertise technique on
appelle ça dans le jargon international
des TSO excusez-moi l'angl technical
safety orization donc l'IRSN c'est un
TSO voilà his ctifi technique alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans le
monde il y a il y a pas mal de système
mais il y a deux grandes références on
va dire qu'il y a le système américain
intégré mais j'aurais quand même
l'occasion d'y revenir parce que la la
présentation est peut-être un peu
caricaturale et puis il y a le système
on va prendre le système français où il
y a une autorité et un expert technique
détaillé les deux systèmes sont reconnus
au niveau international la Ia
d'ailleurs a publie régulièrement des
des documents sur la manière de gérer
les fameux TSO he pour être très précis
le document techdoc 1835 parle que de ça
donc ça c'est le le premier point le
deuxième point c'est je me suivra un
petit exercice j'ai pris les 12 pays
avec le plus de réacteurs donc les
premiers c'est les Américains donc 92 la
France puis la Chine et cetera en fait
sur ces 12 pays il y en a 10 qui ont un
TSO séparé he alors évidemment les deux
qui ont un TSO unique ils sont majeurs
puisque c'est les Américains et les
Canadiens voilà mais le le système est
quand même est quand même est quand même
réparti et l'autre point et je l'avais
dit lors de mon audition la première
audition de l'office parlementaire il
faut faire attention à à à à ne pas
prendre les sujets par appartement
c'estàdire ce que je constate aussi
c'est que l'Autorité de sûreté
américaine l'Autorité de sûreté
canadienne l'autorité de sûrté japonaise
aussi d'ailleurs leurs réunions de de
collège sont publiques par exemple
télévisé hein voilà donc je pense qu'il
faut être attentif à à ne pas prendre
une partie des caractéristiques sans
s'interroger sur l'équilibre global par
ailleurs je signale que le système
américain et le rapport de parlementaire
de du mois de JUET insiste beaucoup
là-dessus et quand un système très
normatif c'est pas un système de
dialogue technique qui favorise la je
crois que le terme de l'Office c'est la
souplesse et le pragmatisme dans
l'approche de sûreté ce dialogue
technique c'est quelque chose qui permet
de laisser la place à l'innovation parce
que c'est pas cadré par des normes à
priori hein donc voilà ce que je peux
dire sur le système sur le
système intégré alors sur le calendrier
qui est évoqué 1er janvier 2025 donc euh
je pense que tout le monde va d'accord
pour partager l'idée que c'est quand
même très ambitieux d'autant plus qu'un
certain de choses pouront pas être
faites tant que la loi n'est pas voter
hein il y a quand même des choix qui
seront dans la loi qui vont conditionner
l'organisation ce qu'on peut dire sur ce
calendrier c'est que si la date du 1er
janvier 2025 est bainu il faudra au 1er
au 1er janvier 2025 un système qui
fonctionne ce sera prob pas le système
définitif parce que le temps est très
court mais il fa un smè qui fonctionne
quand je dis un smè qui fonctionne on
travaille avec l'ASN justement ir ce
qu'on appelle les incontournables
c'est-à-dire c'est quoi les sujets qu'il
faut absolument traiter sinon le sujet
le système ne marche pas alors il a un
exemple trivial qui est évidemment payer
les gens c'est un sujet trivial mais
évidemment essentiel il y a d'autres
sujets il fa qu'il une organisation
quelle qu'elle
soit qui sera intermédiaire entre les
deux ensembles et puis l'installation si
mais où où où les gens auront un poste
attribué dans une hiérarchie avec des
responsabilités des partages de
responsabilités des délégations de
responsabilité et de
pouvoir voilà par ailleurs ça a été
mentionné dans une des
questions il se trouve que le président
de
l'ASN par le le le quitte sa fonction
c'est c'est c'est la loi qui veut ça en
novembre
2024 il serait probablement si cette
structure voit le jour il serait
probablement important me semble-t-il
que le nouveau dirigeant et en main les
options possibles c'està qu'il y a un
travail qui a été préparé en amont et
qu'en novembre celui-ci puisse être
dépositaire de de de de de de de ce
travail la notion de préfigurateur me
semble pas simple après c'est question j
me semble pas simple à traiter puisque
pour être nommé président de la scè
comme directeur général de l'IRSN
d'ailleurs il faut être approuvé par les
commissions parlementaires donc c'est
difficile d'avoir un préfigurateur qui
serait considéré comme étant le futur ou
la future présidente sans être passé par
cette étape euh en tout cas il y a un
travail très important auquel on se
livre avec les équipes de de l'ASN et
pas seulement d'ailleurs avec les
équipes du CA pour la dosimétrie mon mon
petit objet là et les équipes du
ministère des armées sur les les les ce
qu'il faut absolument ce qui doit
absolument être en place au 1er janvier
alors sur les recommandations de
l'opesque donc il y en a il y en a une
une si je fais celle de de février et de
de juillet il y en a une
vingtaine on on retrouve dans la loi une
référence à l'ensemble des
recommandations de de l'Office he les
sujets sont sont sont pris en en en en
considération ce que je voulais
mentionner sur la recommandation du
rapport notamment de enfin sur le
rapport de juillet c'est que à
l'exception de la première qui demande
la fusion les recommandations de l'ofex
pour être développé dans le système
actuel hein voilà
euh vision de la sûreté nucléaire et la
radioprotection de demain alors il a a
il y a deux sujets il y a un un ensemble
de de d'installation nouvelles donc il y
a le Pr le PR2 et les smmr sur le PR2
faut quand même dire que ce il est pas
très éloigné de l'opé actuel hein
puisque finalement la chaudière est la
même la EDF vient de prendre la décision
de garder le même récupérateur de corium
que sur le Pr donc c'est les bâtiments
périphériques qui évoluent c'est
important évidemment mais il y a quand
même une grande similarité et dans
l'expertise du réacteur PR2 qu'on a déjà
commencé on a produit je crois je
regarde Carine une vingtaine d'avis hein
on a déjà produit une vingtaine d'avis
de manière anticipée sur l'expertise du
réacteur PR2 on va s'appuyer sur ce qui
a été fait et on va s'arrêter sur les
distinction les différences avec le le
le réacteur le réacteur
pr actuel et voilà ce que je peux dire
sur le Pr alors sur les nouveaux
réacteurs il y a il y a y a il y a
effectivement un certain nombre de SMR
des petits
réacteur modulaire sur lequel nous
sommes déjà en interaction d'ailleurs
avec les les les concepteurs dans la
démarche d'instruction de ces
nouveaux objets technologiques mais
c'est aussi ces nouveaux acteurs en
nucléaire on a travaillé d'ailleurs avec
la SN pour mettre en place de nouveaux
processus d'instruction pour faire
évoluer le processus d'instruction et
par exemple on a introduit ce qu'on fait
évidemment pas EDF on a introduit une
étape qui va permettre de gagner du
temps qui consiste à à évaluer la
maturité du projet qui va être déposé
par le concepteur de SMR pour voir si ce
projet il est expertisable c'està s'il y
a déjà assez de matière donc ça c'est
clairement une manière d'éviter de
perdre du temps sur un projet qui est
pas assez mû donc ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on a introduit spécifiquement pour
traiter ces ces réacteurs ces nouveaux
réacteurs donc ça nouveau réur et puis
évidemment il y a il y a a a il y a tout
un champ de de sujets qui se renforc he
on a parlé de la la cyber la cyber
sécurité la cyber résidence donc l'IRSN
a engagé depuis quelques années un
renforcement de ces sujets c'est un
sujet majeur le changement climatique
hein on a à la fois des activités de
recherche et d'expertise sur sujet on
avait d'ailleurs été auditionné par par
la Cour des comptes donc oui oui il faut
renforcer le travail sur ces sujets
alors les cinq les cinq enjeux centraux
que qu'a rappelit le le le rapporteur
Pascal Martin alors dans ma présentation
liminaire il y avait une certaine
cohérence entre les deux donc évidemment
le premier sujet c'est c'est
l'attractivité c'est le enfin c'est
l'aspect humain la la force de de l'IRSN
de l'ASN aussi la force de l'IRSN c'est
évidemment la qualité de ces personnes
on a des gens extrêmement diplômés on a
des des ingénieurs des docteurs des
médecins des pharmaciens évidemment un
enjeu dans la durée c'est c'est de c'est
de de réussir à maintenir cette capacité
à
attirer les jeunes femmes et et les
jeunes gens d'ailleurs pas seulement les
jeunes parce qu'on on recrute aussi des
experts de de haut niveau en tout cas on
on essaye donc c'est essentiel il faut
absolument garder cette rctivité dans la
durée clairement la la la période
actuelle est une période d'incertitude
he et donc donc d'inquiétude auprès des
salariés il y a une question sur le sur
le sur l'évolution des des des effectifs
alors on constate clairement une
augmentation des nombres de démissions
ça reste néan mooins modéré hein faut
pas non plus voilà en même temps c'est
souvent sur des gens euh bah qu' va
falloir remplacer on a l'habitude à dire
de dire à l'IRSN il faut 10 ans pour
faire un expert donc quand quelqu'un
part on ninvestit pas tout voilà souvent
on recrute des jeunes donc il faut il
faut investir en la durée donc ça c'est
un point important une des conditions
c'est évidemment les conditions
salariales l'IRSN a fait une étude
euh a fait une étude par un cabinet
spécialisé sur les écarts de salairirees
entre les experts de l'IRSN et et et et
et ceux de l'industrie ou de la santé
puisqu'on est aussi sur le secteur santé
ce qu'on constate c'est qu'en moyenne il
y a un écart de 23 % qui monte à 40 %
sur les experts de bon niveau et les
managers donc c'est clair que c'est
conséquent par ailleurs les nouveaux
acteurs offre clairement des conditions
salariales euh enfin pas
concurrentielles pour un organisme
public comme
comme comme comme l'IRSN il y avait il y
a un enjeu de transparence comme je dit
la transparence elle est essentielle
pour la la la la crédibilité la
confiance dans le dans le système de de
contrôle comme vous savez l'IRSN a une
politique d'ouverture à la société
d'interaction avec le public qui est
volontaire et et dynamique et je crois
mais c'est pas moi de le dire reconnu
donc il faut absolument maintenir et
probablement renforcer encore cette
cette démarche de de transparence on le
fait par dans nos recherches on a un
comité d'orientation de recherche qui
essaie d'associer enfin qui associe les
parties prenantes à la définition des
des des des des programmes de recherche
c'est c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
qu'il faut qu'il faut renforcer avec un
acteur d'ailleurs avec des acteurs
essentiels qui sont les commissions
locales d'information et leur
association nationale avec lequel on a
beaucoup de de de de de de relations et
aussi avec le Haut Comité à la
transparence et information de sécurité
nucléaire demain il y a une conférence
de presse sur le lancement de la
concertation
sur la prolongation des reeurs de 1300
MW à laquelle l'irasn sera présent et
organisé par ce ce comité alors
expertise décision comme je l'ai rappelé
dans mon propos liminire aujourd'hui je
je considère que la proposition
consistant à dire la décion c'est le
collège l'expertise c'est les services
n'est pas
suffisante je peux juste donner un
chiffre pour l'illustrer aujourd'hui le
collège et ça a été dit par l'un d'entre
vous l'une d'entre vous c'est 40
décisions par an l'IRSN donne à l'ASN 40
livrav donc 200 avis la plupart de ces
avis font l'objet d'une reprise donc ça
veut dire que la plupart de ces avis ne
sont pas repris par le collège donc il
sont pas repris par le collège ils sont
repris par les services donc pour nous
c'est un sujet ce qu'il faut approfondir
cette séparation collège décision nous
semes pas euh étuiser le sujet euh ça
peut se faire prent de plein de manières
y compris de en terme organisationnel on
pourra imaginer qu'il y a une décision
une direction de de l'instruction de la
réglementation et une Direction de
l'évaluation avec des processus de prise
de décision au bon endroit dans la dans
la dans la hiérarchie je voudrais aussi
commenter un propos qu'on peut entendre
disant il y a un cont c'est dans le
rapport de l'Office Parlementaire
d'ailleurs il y a un continuum expertise
décision oui il y a un continuum c'estàd
que c'est sujet il commence par le dépôt
d'un dossier par
l'opérateur il y a une discussion entre
l'opérateur la snsn pour définir le
cadre de l'expertise parce qu'on regarde
pas tout dans un dossier hein donc
l'idée c'est identifier ce qu'on va
regarder on regarde les SUF en jeu il y
a une instruction qui enfin une
expertise qui qui comprend des
interactions avec l'opérateur bien
évidemment une information de laasn il y
a une un avis et puis une décision donc
c'est un continuum mais un continuum
n'exclut pas un des étapes et de une
claire attribution des responsabilités
d'ailleurs dans la nouvelle organisation
il y aura une claire attribution des
responsabilité parce que c'est une
démarche qualité mais plus
fondamentalement les experts qui signent
un avis sur du NUC clair ils sont
conscients de la responsabilité qu'il
porte ils sont conscients de la
responsabilité qu' porte et donc quand
ils signent un avis ils tiennent bien ce
que dans la vie il a ce qu'ils ont dit
et pas autre chose hein donc il y aura
de toute façon des process qui
cadenceront ce continuum donc continuum
n'exclut pas le fait qu'il a des étapes
il faudra respecter ces étapes alors sur
la sur la recherche alors c'est
évidemment un enjeu c'est un des enjeux
à mon avis très fort de de la création
de cette nouvelle structure
j'ai évoqué dans mon dans mon dans mon
dans mon propos liminaire l'insertion
dans l'écosystème de la recherche donc
c'est évidemment un enjeu très important
pourquoi parce que les modes de
fonctionnement d'une autorité de sûreté
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui de
recherche sont pas les mêmes l'Autorité
de sûreté j'ai été directeur général de
l'ASN pendant 10 ans donc je vois à peu
près de quoi il s'agit le fonctionnement
d'une autorité c'est c'est un
fonctionnement qui en surplomb c'est une
autorité c'est normal c'est ce qu'on
attendait là en sur plomb le fonction d'
de recherche c'est plutôt de la
collaboration compétition les Oris de
recherche sont là pour collaborer en
même temps il y a de la compétition pour
répondre à des appels à projet pour
construire des partenariats donc on voit
qu'il va falloir comer ces choses rien
n'est impossible mais c'est un sujet
important j'ai mentionné aussi le le
dans dans nos relations à l'IRSN
aujourd'hui tous nos partenaires nous
interrogent sur le sujet j'étais à la
Conférence générale de laa septembre
j'ai eu je crois 25 rendez-vous c'est
l'occasion d'avoir plein de rendez-vous
j'ai eu 25 fois la question hein voilà
euh euh euh euh l'autre sujet que j'ai
évoqué mon intervention c'est le lien
avec les industriels pour nous c'est
fondamental il faut pas faire de la
recherche hors sol de la recherche
théorique euh voilà il faut faire de la
recherche opérationnelle c'est répondre
à un besoin d'expertise d'ailleurs je
rappelle que IRSN a cr a été créé en en
dans les années 2000 avec cet objectif
c'estir créer une interaction entre la
recherche et l'expertise pour pour que
la l'expertise soit du meilleur niveau
avec les meilleures connaissances c'est
là où je rejoins la discussion avec la
la NRC autorité de surté américaine on
est dans un système qui a de la
flexibilité de la souplesse du
pragmatisme parce qu' il y a ce dialogue
technique qui est fondé sur la
connaissance scientifique en en
américain on appelle ça en anglais on
appelle ça science base donc ça c'est
évidemment important de faire de la
recherche concrète et une bonne manière
de faire la recherche concrète c'est de
discuter avec les industriels et de
confronter les points de vue les
approches il y a un sujet majeur c'est
le sujet de la ologie aujourd'hui l'IRSN
en tant qu'organise d'expertise pour les
les les autorités les pouvoirs publics
est déjà confronté à ce sujet nous le
traitons nous avons notamment une
commission d'éthique et de déontologie
je pense que la nouvelle autorité
devrait se doter d'une commission
d'éthique et déontologie une commission
d'éthique et déontologie qui analyse les
modalités de notre relation et tous les
ans nous présentons à cette commission
un état de de ce que nous de ce que nous
de ce que nous faisons pour le le la
diontologie l'autre facteur essentiel me
semble-t-il c'est que les programmes de
recherche que l'IRSN conduit avec EDF
par exemple sont jamais des têtes à-tête
c'estàdire que c'est des partenariats
donc il y a plein d'acteurs hein donc ça
peut être des TSO étrangers ça peut être
des organises académiques ça peut être
d'autres industriels donc ça c'est aussi
une garantie pour
que l'IRSN et tout à fait ça ça voie y
compris dans le le le cas d'une relation
avec les les les industriels et le
dernier point que j'ai mentionné il fa
évid que a la capacité à continu
continuer à devoir exploiter construire
et exploiter des des des des
installations de recherche sur le
juridique alors c'est vrai que dans le
projet de loi tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de références il y a
beaucoup de références au règlement
intérieur ont été cité la déontologie la
transparence c'est parti expertise
décision c'est effectivement très
structurant j'ai j'ai rappelé que sur
ces trois points là je consid que c'est
des points de grande vigilance et de ce
point de vuel une implication de la la
présentation
nationale me semblerait bénéfique sur le
fond mais aussi en terme de perception
par le par le par par par par le public
donc tout vous proposz et proposer une
saisine pour par l'opes j'ai pas
forcément d'idée sur les modalité je
pense ce serait bénéfique de la même
manière d'ailleurs que il pourrait y
avoir une et je pense que c'est une des
recommandations de l'Office une des une
une une intervention du Haut Comité à la
transparence information de sécurité
nucléire tout ça me semble être être
positif alors sur les articles lié à la
commande publique et au Haut Commissaire
alors en fait l'IRSN a peu de chos à
dire sur ces sujets enfin même pas de
chos à dire je vrais juste mentionner
que le haut commissaire joue un rôle
dans la recherche c'est vrai que dès que
il sera institué dans son nouveau statut
l'IRSN l'IRSN prendra contact avec lui
ou la nouvelle structure pour évoquer
les enjeux de la recherche dans la
sûreté nucléaire à un moment où
d'ailleurs il y a un travail de
organisation de la la de la la la de la
recherche alors j'avais une j'avais une
question sur l'application de la réforme
et leschang je crois que j'ai déjà
répondu hein à la fois s tendu il faut
que ce soit opérationnel au 1er janvier
2025 et puis il y a il se trouve que
c'est corrélatif en ça correspond au au
mandat d'un d'un nouveau président d'une
nouvelle Présidente je crois que j'ai
j'ai j'ai déjà répondu une question sur
le stat sur le statut ai API hein alors
ce qui est clair c'est
que l'API présenterait par rapport au
statut de
l'irasn beaucoup plus de facilité de
mise en œuvre je vous donne un exemple
le le système de le S système
d'information et de gestion c'est ça que
ça veut dire donc c'est le système qui
permet de finalement gérer toutes les
procédures budget achat RH et cetera
dans les organismes dans laqun on en a
un qu'on a mis en place d'ailleurs à la
création de l'IRSN il y a il y a
longtemps demain si c'est une AAI on
devra se se brancher sur le SIG de
l'État qui s'appelle Corus alors je sais
pas si vous êtes familier des systèmes
informatiques mais c'est un travail qui
est très important qui est considérable
c'est vrai que c'était une API on
pourrait garder notre système voilà il y
a un certain nombre de sujets pourquoi
parce que l'iasn a la personnalité
morale contrairement à une ai la p a une
une personnalité morale donc clairement
la pay serait de nature à simplifier euh
la mise en œuvre du process tu aura
besoin quand même de disposition dans la
loi hein mais voilà ensuite sur les
missions j'avais une question sur la la
sécurité euh sécurité des installations
nucléaires civiles donc c'est c'est le
choix fait par le gouvernement donc ce
que je peux dire c'est que euh
euh ce que je peux dire c'est que dans
la plupart des pays mais je pense que le
président de la SCN a dû vous le dire la
plupart des pays la sécurité et euh est
intégré à l'Autorité de sûreté ce qui me
semble important c'est de rappeler c'est
de
rappeler les la sécurité ça a plusieurs
dimensions donc c'est tout ce qui a
trait au terrorisme et en fait dans la
prévention le traitement d'unr
terroriste il y a deux dimensions une
dimension technique d'organisation c'est
il faut qu'il détecteur des des des
portes épaisses des portes épaisses des
des des une organisation avec des gens
prêts intervenir et cetera donc ça c'est
un peu comme les études de sûreté ça
peut être analysé ça peut être du du
ressort d'une autorité de sûreté ou de
sécurité et et puis après il y a aussi
dans ce domaine spécifique par rapport à
la sûreté il y a des services
spécialisés il y a la police les
gendarmes les services secrets et ça
dans aucun pays ça n'appartient à
l'autorité de de sûreté hein donc s'il y
avait une réflexion à conduire sur ce
sujet elle se limiterait à la dimension
technique évidemment et
organisationnelle he elle couvrirait pas
les services secrets les services
d'intervention t t tous ces organismes
là sont dans les instances qui vont bien
défense intérieure par contre voilà
c'est tout ce que je peux dire sur ce
sur ce sur ce sujet
euh séparation expertise décision par je
l'ai déjà évoqué hein l'IRSN donc je le
rappelle fait 400 livrables à l'IRSN à
l'ASN tous les ans dont 200 avis il y a
40 décisions de laasn donc il y a
beaucoup de décisions qui sont prises en
dehors de en dehors du du du du collège
c'est un sujet qu'il faut aborder sur la
publication des des sur la publication
des des éléments techniques des avis moi
il me semble fondamental mais c'est
aussi euh une recommandation d'un
certain nombre de de de d'organismes qui
ont été s il y a l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques le
auut Conseil un certain nombre de
conseil le conseil sur la nationale sur
la transition écologique tous vont dans
le même sens évidemment j'adère tout à
fait à ça il faut continu tu à rendre
les éléments tous les avis en plus hein
c'estàd que euh même les avis qui sont
pas forcément suite de décision je pense
qu'il faudra travailler sur le fait que
l'ensemble des avis soit rend du public
de la de même manière que les
que les recherches un point sur les sur
les personnels donc j'ai j'ai mentionné
dans mon intervention que le
l'organisation envisagée elle a une
complexité certaine c'est là c'est pas
moi qui le dit hein c'est c'est
notamment le le le le le Conseil d'État
et cette complexité elle est notamment
liée au fait que dans une aaiï autorité
administra inter donc un bout d'État
sans personnalité moral il faut
intégrer 1600 personnels de de droit
privé alors je rappelle que pour ce pour
ce sujet d'intégration des personn troit
privé il y a trois il y a trois TR trois
sujets en fait le premier sujet c'est
c'est le statut des gens leur salaire
pour faire cours le deuxième sujet c'est
ce qu'on appelle le dispositif
conventionnel c'est par exemple
l'astreinte les gensn font des
astreintes certains c'est
essentiellement des techniciens ont des
suggestions he c'està-dire qu'il faut
qu'ils aillent sur les sites
régulièrement pour vérifier que il y a
pas de problème technique ça peut être
la
mutuelle les PES et autres outil de ce
type donc ça c'est conventionnel he donc
ça aussi ça va traité la troisème
dimension c'est évidemment euh la la
structuration de l'autorité pour
permettre le dialogue social avec les
partenaires sociaux donc c'est ça qui
est dans la loi il y a y a y a il y a
une a à peu près une petite vingtaine
d'articles un tiers des articles sont
consacrés à à ce sujet qui traduit
effectivement cette cette cette
dimension sur la délégation au aux
agents étrangers et privés alors c'est
c'est pas le champ de l'IRS donc je suis
je je suis pas très compétent sur ce je
ne sais pas répondre à cette question
alors euh en plus j'avais une question
sur est-ce que le système actuel
pourrait pourrait faire face à
l'évolution en courant
euh moi ma perception c'est que je l'ai
évoqué il me semble qu'and des une
condition du du du du plan de relance
nucléaire c'est les moyens et je pense
que c'est vraiment une question
importante je pense que l'IRSN a fait la
preuve avec laasn d'ailleurs dans dans
le passé de sa capacité à s'adapter à
une nouvelle situation je donne
l'exemple de de Fukushima Fukushima on
s'est retrouvé du jour au lendemain à
travailler pendant plusieurs mois sur un
sujet qui était évidemment inattendu sur
lequel on a réussi à à à à s'adapter et
à travailler à travailler en parallèle
d'autres sujets donc il me semble que le
système actuel pourra évoluer euh pour
se rendre encore plus performant
d'ailleurs on a des groupes de travail
je pense que ça a été évqué par Bernard
deosu qui a 12 groupes de travail qui
travaillent sur l'élaboration de la
future autorité et en fait ces groupes
de travail identifi des pistes des
pistes de d'amélioration là Karine est
impliqué dans celui sur sur expertise
décision instruction tu veux peut-être
en dire un mot rapidement là c'est très
rapidement
oui nous avons travaillé récemment à la
à une meilleure articulation entre les
les
processus puisque nous avons des
activités qui sont assez complémentaires
entre entre l'IRSN et laasn et nous
avons revu finalement le le séquencement
les étapes pour essayer de de de
simplifier ou en tout cas de de limiter
la fin du processus d'expertise qui est
un petit peu lourde dans dans les
échanges avec les exploitants alors il
faudra veiller à ce que cela ne n'ober
pas finalement la la
maturité la maturation plutôt de du
projet de décision Infiné mais les les
échanges avancent bien il devrait même
d'ailleurs être testé je pense avant la
avant le 1er janvier 2025 puisque rien
n'empêche de de faire évoluer nos
processus en l'état c'est aussi le cas
pour la crise et effectivement faire ça
dans le stème actuel ça éviterait un des
un des enjeux que j'ai mentionné qui
évidemment la la le risque sur la
continuité de service par rapport à au
chantiers qu'il a à conduire c'est vrai
que ce serait évidemment une garantie
plus forte sur la continuité no nos
activités alors ensuite il y avait une
une question sur les doublons avec laasn
alors moi je considère qu' y a pas de
doublon avec la SN dans les champs
métiers sur les champs sur les champs
fonctionnel et support bah il y a il y a
une Direction des Ressources humaines
des deux côtés il y a une direction de
la communication et cetera mais mais sur
les champs métiers je considère qu'il y
a pas de doublon par contre ce qui est
clair c'est que donc il y a de la
complémentarité ce qui est clair dans
l'esprit de ce que vient de dire kW
c'est qu'on peut renforcer cette
complémentarité on peut aller plus loin
dans dans dans la la complémentarité de
de de nos de nos missions il y a y avait
une question sur le règlement intérieur
donc j'y reviens pas je pense qu'il faut
que le règlement intérieur soit soit
effectivement partagé notamment avec la
la la r la la représentation nationale
alors
euh ensuite j'avais un une question sur
la place de l'ASN etn à l'international
là encore il y a c'est clairement un
sujet sur lequel une une entité judique
renforcerait le positionnement
interational de l'ASN et l'ASN les deux
sont reconnus ça pourrait être aussi
fait dès maintenant he ça fait partie
des sujets qui ne nécessitent pas qui
peuvent être pris dès maintenant en
compte si la nouvelle autorité secret
c'est clairement un des sujets comme le
partage des données qui qui qui qui qui
qui serait qui serait renforcé euh sur
la j'ai une question sur la séparation
défense civile donc pour être très
précis aujourd'hui le schéma tel qu'il
est prévu sur la défense ce serait que
rejoigne le ministère des armées de
sujets donc ça sera au sein de
l'Autorité de sûreté défense de sujets
il y a la sûreté des installations de
défense donc la sûreté des installations
de défense c'est éviter les accidents
sur les installations le réacteur du
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle ou sur les
installations qui fabriquent des armes
nucléaires donc c'est des installations
dédiées au besoins de la défense et
rejoindrait aussi cette autorité la
sécurité des installations civiles hein
donc il y aurait deux blocs il aurait
sûreté des instations de défense et les
accidents sur de défense et et sécurité
des instations civiles c'est les risques
terroristes sur sur les installations
euh civiles donc clairement pour moi un
des enjeux de de la de du de ce que j'ai
appelé le chantier expertise défense
c'est clairement la gestion des
interfaces hein puisque pour l'expertise
de sécurité civile pour pour l'expertise
de sûreté défense pardon le l'Autorité
de sûreté défense devra faire appel aux
experts spécialistes de l'incendie de la
neutronique de la thermohydraulique aux
experts spécialistes qui seront dans le
autorité civile hein c'està-dire que
l'Autorité de sûreté de défense elle va
prendre les ce qu'on appelle les
généralistes c'est les gens qui
regardent une installation
dansalité dès qu'ils vont s'adresser à
un risque spécialisé ils devront
travailler avec ce spécialiste au sein
de l'autorité civile donc ça c'est un
sujet d'interface il faudra mettre en
place des conventions et des des sujets
pour traiter et des des modalités pour
traiter pour traiter ça il y a un autre
suet c'est la crise aujourd'hui l'IRSN
fait l'expertise de La Défense c'est du
civil donc s'il y a un accident on le
fait par en exercice de crise sur une
installation de défense ça se fait dans
notre centre de crise ce centre de crise
il a vocation à rejoindre l'autorité de
seté civile la SNR donc il y a une
question de comment la crise défense va
être organisé c'est un sujet sur lequel
il y a des des travaux des travaux en
cours sur les travaux avec les
partenaires industriels je je donc j'ai
évoqué les enjeux de déontologie là il y
a une question qui est posée sur lequel
je je je peux pas répondre à ce stade
mais qui est une vraie question c'est la
la rence éventuelle des industriels à
trac lirsn avec laasnr donc ça ce sera
je dirais ce sera à l'épreuve en tout
état de cause un préalable c'est de
traiter ces sujets de de de déontologie
alors il y a une question sur la gestion
des d'un d'un flux de demande important
alors comment on traite ça aujourd'hui
alors j'avais l'occasion de de de de
devant le le la représentation
parlementaire dans d'autres cases
budgétaire notamment ou lors de ma nom
tion il y a quelques années d'évoquer le
fait que la pression de l'expertise
avait conduit à à réduire le volume de
la recherche à l'IRSN donc c'est clair
quand il y a une pression forte ça peut
avoir un effet sur d'autres domaines
sinon on a des on a on peut aussi se
voir attribuer des moyens
supplémentaires l'IRSN on a eu un
certain nombre ces dernières années
notamment suite au rapport de la Cour
des comptes sinon c'est un travail qui
consiste à hiérarchiser les demandes
hein donc on a aussi un travail là
encore avec la SN et les opérateurs pour
être plus efficace dans la demande je
donne un exemple d'ailleurs c'est cité
dans le rapport de l'Office
traditionnellement quand on reçoit un
dossier de l'opérateur nos experts
travaillent puis commencent par poser
des questions au celui qui pose le
dossier une partie de ces questions sont
les questions de compréhension c'est il
y a pas d'enjeu c'est juste de
comprendre ce que ce que veut dire
l'opérateur ça c'est vrai que c'est un
peu lourd donc aujourd'hui on a mis en
place pour les gros dossier un système
de séminaire commun de un ou de jours où
on traite de manière extrêmement rapide
ces questions de compréhension voyz donc
vous voyez donc ça c'est une manière de
c'est une manière d'améliorer le système
et il y a probablement des des des des
gains des gains des gains à faire il y a
une question sur se poser des des
questions hors commande bon ben c'est un
point essentiel il faut que cette
capacité reste il faut avoir la une
capacité d'étonnement enfin c'est
l'effet lampadaire c'est il faut avoir
la capacité à regarder en dehors du
lampadaire c'est essentiel pour la
gestion du
risque sur les aspects humains et
personnels je crois que j'ai déjà
largement répondu hein sur le nouveau
nucléaire donc il y a le sujet des des
sites des nouveaux sites alors moi je
n'ai pas d'information à ce sujet sur
des sites qui seraient on voit des
choses dans les médias et mais des sites
qui seraient officiellement désignés
j'en connais pas ce qui est clair c'est
que je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
nouvelle structure où laasn l'ASN
devront être impliqué dans dans
l'explication de de du système de
contrôle et des enjeux de sûreté
nucléaire de Radi protection et je pense
qu'il faudrait créer des commissions
locales d'information qui sont de mon
point de vue des des des des des des qui
un dispositif qui est intéressant
d'ailleurs un disp if sur lequel des
acteurs internationaux peuvent venir
nous nous voir recherche une question
sur l'affablissement dans la durée donc
là j'ai déjà
évoqué sur civo alors je je sur la
question de civo alors déjà sur la
corrosion sous contrainte hein là encore
c'est dans le rapport de l'Office
Parlementaire à deux endroits
d'ailleurs l'Office Parlementaire
constate après les auditions que ça a
été traité correctement avec digigence
et un autre endroit du rapport il est
mentionné suite d'ailleurs à une une un
travail fait par Ed
que les partenaires internationaux
n'auraient pas fonctionné différemment
donc ça c'est le casadre général et sur
civo il se trouve que c'était c'était un
dossier qui a été géré sans expertise de
l'IRSN il y avait pas besoin d'expertise
et donc ça avait fait des dans desl
relativement court je parle sous
contrôle de Karine tu peux peut-être en
dire un mot Karine ou en fait
l'autorisation proprement dite pour le
redémarrage de civo a été gérée
directement par l'Autorité de sûreté et
donc la la demande de DF de redémarrage
a été déposée le 13 janvier
l'autorisation délivrée par l'ASN le le
17 parce qu'en fait cette centrale était
en pleine visite décenale donc il y
avait non seulement laffire de la
corrosion sous contrainte mais il
fallait bien terminer la visite
descenale ce qui explique que la demande
de DF de redémarrage a été faite plus
tardivement par rapport au au seul
problème de la corrosion sous
contrainte merci Karine donc j'avais une
question sur la finalement est-ce que la
fusion améliorit les les les les temps
de réponsse moi je voulais quand même
assister aujourd'hui sur
relation SN IRSN le fait que l'IRSN est
des demandeurs des donneurs d'ordre en
fait est un facteur très puissant dans
le respect des échéances d'ailleurs le
respect des échéances c'est quelque
chose qui est suiv par nos donneurs
d'ord l'Autorité de sûreté mais tous les
donneurs d'ordre et je constate que ils
sont suivis de manière factuelle et ça
donne lieu à des réunions sur ce sujet
et que l'IRSN respecte très bien les
échanges qui sont donnés hein donc cette
logique client fourniss donneur d'ordre
est un système qui qui qui marche on
travaille dans les groupes de travail
sur la manière dont on pourrait encore
améliorer le système dans le système
actuel ou dans le le futur système j'ai
une nouvelle question sur les
rémunération les 15
millions donc c'est 15 millions qui sera
à prendre sur le budget deirsn
aujourd'hui c'est pas une une
attribution
supplémentaire et ça correspond une
augmentation de budget de l'ordre de 10
% et par rapport au chiffres que j'ai
évoqué tout d'ailleurs c'est clair que
ce serait un un facteur de fidélisation
et d'attractivité il y a les deux il y a
la fidélisation c'est garder les gens
qu'on a c'est l'enjeu d'expert
compétents qui s'en va P d'attractivité
qui viennent autres P d'attractivité bon
c'est clairement la période d' d'incer
actuelle pas favorable donc il faudrait
revenir à une une situation plus plus
plus stabilisée
ensuite
euh l'évolution a apporté au modèle
actuel en fonction des normes donc j'ai
j'ai j'ai évoqué ça tout à l'heure on
vous laissera le le document qui montre
les échéances il y a beaucoup
d'échéances en 2024 2025 et il y a un
rebond en 2026 de
2027 c'est quand même pour une partie
une question de moyen hein et puis une
question d'organisation donc c'est le
travail auquel auquel on on on on se
livre là j'arrive à ma dernière question
qui est à laquelle j'ai déjà répondu
c'était le caractère intégré des des des
autorités madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président Monsieur mesam j'ai répond
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur
Général merci Monsieur le Directeur
Général pour effectivement avoir répondu
aux questions de de nos cè